bienvenue à tous dans cette nouvelle
saison de pas fonder tout à fait ravis
de vous retrouver j'espère que vous êtes
aussi ravis de nous retrouver on va
parler de beaucoup de sujets aujourd'hui
on va parler des réfugiés on va parler
de la conférence de presse de françois
hollande fait tousser un petit peu au
havre une voix à peu près normal et je
vous présente les participants à cette
émission
stéphane mon sens bonjourbonjour patrice
toujours à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin oui jusqu'à
proposer ce jour là encore toujours
toujours est ravie de vous retrouver et
nous aussi
florence mercadé choqué bonjour jean
patrice toujours avocate aussi au
barreau de versailles au maroc 4-0 avec
un cabinet à saint quentin
on peut dire ça comme ça spécialiste du
droit du travail notamment et on va
beaucoup parler du travail puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de la réforme du droit du
travail vous avez amené le code qui est
tout le monde dit qu'il est trop gros
trop épais trop compliqué on va voir
s'il faut vraiment le coupé le
simplifier c'est une bonne solution
avec nous une nouvelle venue féliciter
andy comme bonjour
les 'lionnes' dirais qui tu savais pas
mais j'avais du mou donc je dis partout
vous êtes comédienne et vous nous
rejoignez pour cette année on est
absolument ravie de vous recevoir
voilà et donc vous serez une nouvelle
membre du paf et je n'avais pas de
chance là je me dis qu'est le plus
méchant de cette équipe mais qui est un
excellent tennis terre et qui édite son
dernier lycée au dessus des horizons
verticaux c'est un roman policier alors
on va dire comment un petit mot
déjà de l'auteur de de l'auteur russie
qui est olivier morel qu'on a connue qui
a été qu était le directeur de la
centrale de poissy
voilà c'était une grande carrière dans
le ministre dans l'administration
pénitentiaire lui effectivement bien
connue des yvelinois parce qu'il est
resté je crois que trois ou quatre ans à
poissy et oui là il a bien mené 7 cette
centrale qui est assez compliquée parce
que d'abord en plein centre ville
et puis et puis thierry avec les tenues
et les condamnés qui sont pas 10 des
voleur de mobylette et avec qui faisait
des dd kroes il est facile un autre
sport d'éthique sportive simon est
patent c'est un gars des expos pris en
otage c'est un gars très vite arriver si
c'est un type absolument extraordinaire
voilà et et qui avait raconté d'ailleurs
sa vie de directeur de prison dans un
précédent livre hélas hélas et c'est un
polar au dessus des horizons verticaux
on le recommande
d'abord parce que l'histoire était assez
extraordinaire c'est comment cependant
penser à la mort d'hitler ça commence
dans le bunker d'hitler dix plaies et ça
se termine
pas très loin d'ici aujourd'hui je n'en
dis pas plus et ayez une hallucinante
scène dans une prison et qui vu la
personnalité de l'auteur sait c'est du
véhicule cdu c'est du jour voici si
jamais olivier morel sous préfet à
cognac
mais si un jour il a l'occasion de venir
ici on le recevra avec un grand plaisir
je veux lui dire il va être à 20 h c'est
vrai qu'il a une expérience absolument
extraordinaire alors on va commencer
avec avec ce qui est une qualité qui
s'était déjà produite il ya quelques
mois
enfin il ya une polémique avec la
sculpture d'un discours à versailles
elle a été taguée cette semaine elle été
retaillée dans la nuit jeudi à vendredi
on va voir peut-être d'abord un petit
micro-trottoir de ce que pensent les
gens de de cette sorte d'attentats et
puis on en parle tout de suite après
celle à un câble je pense que c'est des
gens qui ont bien compris qu'ils
cherchent se faire remarquer mais non
seulement ça me choque mais ça me fait
peur une telle violence une telle
intolérance
on aime ou on n'aime pas mais on n'est
pas obligé de regarder on détruit des
monuments et puis même les oeuvres même
temps contemporains ils sont moches mais
enfin moi c'est quand même pas faire à
mon avis il ne pouvait pas être tout
seul pour écrire aussi pour y faire
autant le texte
il va être certainement plusieurs je
suppose c'est vraiment ridicule et
complètement dépassée de nos jours des
réactions pareil et le fait que
l'artiste soit laissée du coup l'état du
sociologue
mais la raison comme ça il fait voir la
bêtise des gens voilà donc les vieux
sont contre le napa pas contre le mal de
la reine qu'on peut conclure de ce trail
celui contre toi maintenant s'il y avait
des jeunes vers le port est vrai bien
aussi savoir s'il fonce mais qu'est-ce
qu'il ya eu un autre tag cette nuit
alors qu'il dit en gros quand on croit
en dieu on n'attaque pas là donc c'est
visiblement
un tag en titane quoi est-ce que les
premières inscriptions étaient plutôt
des inscriptions antisémites alors il ya
plusieurs choses il ya d'abord le fait
qu'un disque pour ali ben voilà il ya eu
ces inscriptions antisémites on les
touche pas on les garde
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à florence
cliquez ici jose jose
j'ose penser quelque chose je crois que
le problème c'est le traitement de
l'intégration de ces de ses écrits pour
pas que le sens ne viennent que de
l'auteur c'est à dire que là en ce
moment on a un sens qui est un sens
antisémite plus le tac de cette nuit
dont on sait pas bien en fait quand même
si c'est une critique ou une critique
vis-à-vis beloteurs l'impression en
disant wenger ne respecte pas l'art et
tu ne crois pas en dieu enfin je sais
pas très bien comment le prendre alors
duo doit respecter l'arrogance et la
série va la vie c'est une défense
je ne sais pas phase 2 donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une vraie une
véritable explication aussi bien d'anish
kapoor que de catherine pégard la
présidente du château de versailles avec
un écriteau mais je pense que c'est
peut-être qu'ils vont faire pour qu'ils
expliquent pourquoi et pourquoi y avait
moi il conserve
oui parce que dans dix ans c'est un
festival ça reste et ça reste est pure
la sculpture va pas être détruite donc
si on l'avait un peu comme ça non mais
tu as menée sur deux ans dont c'était
pas dans trois siècles c'est des genres
ex aequo cette sculpture pour se dire
tiens antisémite avait pas quoi mais il
faut qu'il y ait un panneau explicatif
pour que le sens que nous on veut donner
enfin en tout cas qu anish kapoor veut
donner à ce maintien des inscriptions
s'impose sur le sens aucun voulu donner
l'auteur de ces salaires explique éric
ya déjà un petit pas nous qui a été ni
mais c'est en scotch quelque chose d'un
peu provisoire qui expliquait pourquoi
on avait maintenu les graffitis pour
l'instant mais c'était juste dire que
l'auteur avait demandé que
si c'était juste provisoire je pense que
peut-être que par la suite
et puis il ne s'attendait pas à ce
qu'ils ont mis la pression lundi
sécurité au château de versailles réglés
puisqu'il exige langage des vigiles des
maîtres chiens des caméras ça veut dire
comment un vrai beau nom a longtemps dû
réduire à chaque fois qu'on a plus de
sécurité je trouve ça toujours plus mais
surtout pour ça après une fois que ce
truc sera entièrement taguée
je veux dire il y aura plus de place
puissent-ils amish capua ça lui fait
plaisir si ça l'est mais pas si je
gardais les inscrits non mais si vous
regardez les inscriptions cabessut
autant que ça devienne comme une espèce
de mur d'expression c'est pas gênant été
recensés ces sapir moi mon sens c'est sa
pire peuvent venir les autres cas le
jardin dans le parc de versailles sont
belles intéressante celle là c'est juste
moche après c'est tout le débat se
comprend très bien ce qu'on aime ou on
n'aime pas moi j'ai rien contre le fait
que la musique a pour toi versailles
mais celle-là écoute positivement l'aide
et c'est vrai qu'on comprend presque edc
on dirait presque un égout à ciel ouvert
que que les gens en ville aller taguer
quelque chose on leur a proposé depuis
d'aider des dizaines d'années de taguer
les murs propres de taguer les belles
maisons de 2to taille et pourquoi ne pas
taguer ça le message est choquant sa
saveur satrem peut faire de street art
s'il venait voir aplec aller jusqu'à
pour et israéliens c'est totalement
idiot je trouve c'est l'ailé c'est parce
que vraiment ça une publicité aux
abrutis qui ont augmenté qui ont inscrit
ses propos et ça nous avons la joie dans
son sens à lui aussi puisque c'est un
artiste qui aime provoquer donc dans ce
sens là il a obtenu aussi une réponse à
ce qu'ils voulaient envoyer parce que la
traduction qu'il a donné un bol d'air
pour renvoyer quelque chose va appeler
une réponse à le salir
notre ouïe et l'analyse de fin de sa
tête mais il va chercher il a il
chercher quand même a lancé une forme
grave de provocation le fait d'intégrer
la critique à l'oeuvre elle-même enfin
c'est aussi son parti alors pourquoi pas
je trouve ça assez amusant moi je
pensais mais ça n'a rien à voir faut à
quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup qui
est là je cours de la joconde à
moustache
oui celle du chant non ce n'est pas
l'oeuvre originale sur laquelle il a en
fait il n'y a pas fait une moustache sur
la vraie joconde
mais c'était aussi très provocant
provocateur moi j'ai je travaille chez
moi devant la joconde à moustache que je
préfère même à l'original mais là on est
dans des considérations qui sont au
regard du message qui est laissée par
ces par ces inscriptions enfin intégrer
la critique à l'oeuvre elle même je
pense qu'on pourrait s'en dispenser
mettant le tac de cette nuit est une
critique puisqu ils sont su mêler le tac
d'avancé antisémite n'est pas une
critique
j'ai dit une bêtise que personne d un
personnage il est évidemment à dire non
mais je suis content du tout serait il
est d'origine aborigène vous avez vous
que vous aviez eu la délicate
le vbcc duquel et les informations quand
patrice c'est vous le maître c'est donc
finalement c'est pas mal c'est d'offres
qui vicois a su se hisser le spectacle
vivant on ne s'attendait pas à ce que ce
qu'une oeuvre de ce genre la soi-disante
mail est vrai mais ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'elle émigrait un petit
auparavant il se trouve qu'on enregistre
cette émission on est en 11 septembre 11
septembre 2015 donc il ya 14 ans et une
petit calcul bien c'était le 11
septembre 2001
évidemment c'est un des événements dont
tout le monde se vient tout le monde se
souvient ce qui faisait à cette heure là
vous en serez évidemment voir vous en
souvenez tous ce que vous est ce que est
ce que votre avis est l'événement
fondateur de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui de xxième
siècle ou où est-ce qu'on exagère la
portée de ces attentats je suis assez
d'accord avec cette analyse
vous savez pour les historiens en
histoire contemporaine le xxème siècle
ne commence à 1914 et je je l'histoire
le dira et ça encore une fois on ne le
sait qu'après mais je pense que c'est
quand même significatif d'un basculement
dans autre chose dans par exemple
l'internationalisation à très grande
échelle du terrorisme sur un territoire
qui s'enn estimait protéger une espèce
de multinationales du du mal du
terrorisme alors on voyait ça avant dans
les paroles et james bond et c'est avec
le méchant qui en appuyant sur un bouton
avait un pouvoir considère mais voilà ce
que nous dit aussi le 11 septembre c'est
que ça ce n'est plus de la fiction que
la réalité a rejoint la fiction et que
finalement la mondialisation elle
concerne aussi ce que bush avait appelé
les forces du mal
oui je pense que je sais pas je suis pas
sûr que le nombre était très différente
s'il n'y avait pas eu le 11 septembre
2001 parce que c'était un comprimé tout
ça quand même puis héroïsme oui mais bon
de terrorisme existaient déjà et tout ça
puisse vraiment ses sources dans le
conflit israélo-palestinien à l'origine
après derrière ça une télé ni traînée de
poudre et sa femme un peu explosé tout
ça ça a permis aux américains d'avoir
enfin un ennemi puisque il avait bu il
n'avait plus l'urss y faire mesurer à
l'épidémie est enfin ils ont pu
retrouver un ennemi pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir attaquer après oui on a la garde
on à la guerre en irak est tous là où on
en est aujourd'hui
mais c'est scandaleux de dire une chose
pareille que c'est plus permettre aux
états unis de trouver un ennemi c on
dirait du noël mamère c'est comme s'ils
avaient cessé
mais ces mots c'est le monde à l'envers
c'est à dire qu' il ya des terroristes
qui attaque un pays et vous êtes en
train de dire ça permet aux états unis
5,2 attaquer l'irak concours autant
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
c'était une grosse erreur mais qu'après
la tirant d eau par votre l'irak
il attendait depuis un moment d'y aller
ça aussi eterna les gens qui étaient
censés mener des gens qui étaient
sensibles au massacre des kurdes
visiblement il y en a plein qui s'en
foutent mais voilà son pool pas non plus
cette indignation sélective salem
hussein massacrer les kurdes tous les
matins tout le monde s'en foutait
bon effectivement bah moi ça ne me
dérange pas plus que ça je connais pas
de kurdes mais intellectuellement c'est
quand même très gênant enfin les
personnes
personne ne disait oh bah non c'est pas
grave et qu'il faisait pas de dire si
c'est pas grave c'est de dire on se rend
compte aujourd'hui et c'est toujours
pareil c'est quand on a le décalage
c'est qu'on avait peut-être d'autres
réponses à donner que la guerre en irak
oui mais la suite de cet événement à
quetta comme angers comment aussi eric
comment signac après celui en aragon
monde comme en tunisie comme dans l'art
comme dans tous les pays où on dit
finalement est-ce qu'il vaut mieux un
ou de mise à l'eau ou un trois
quarts de salou on va laisser faire les
ados on va demi salou pour et ont essayé
de d'instaurer à la place de celui là
voilà enfin bon mais en tout cas pour
revenir à la question mais je trouve
qu'effectivement c'est un marqueur hyper
important le puis ça change
au delà de la politique et donnant par
là pour changer l'énergie -2 d'articles
11 septembre il ya eu pendant pendant
une dizaine d'années sont aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus en plus on ne voyage plus
pareil on ne pense plus pareil on ne
regarde plus les gens de la même façon
mais on met effectivement un peu
terrorisé on peut dire que c'est pas
très grave
on s'en fout mais enfin c'est vrai que
c'est habitent et maintenant garde est
d'aider des gens et des gens en armes
24 heures sur 24 dans toutes les
démocraties alors c'est ce qui était
quand même un truc avant selon septembre
on voyait pas des soldats gare
montparnasse en permanence féliciter
vous souvenez de ce que vous faisiez
septembre 2001 oui j'étais à parly 2 gta
parler d'eux et on s'était tous à
conserver devant la vitrine d'un grand
magasin en des télévisions va dire ah
oui pour regarder ce qui se disait
et j'ai vraiment eu l'impression je suis
d'accord avec florence que c'était un
petit peu un passe-droit maintenant
légitime et pour les états unis
d'intervenir comme ça au proche-orient
ma vie au moyen-orient' vraiment
l'impression que ça m'a donné et le
début d'une troisième guerre mondiale
larvée en fait dont on s'imprègne delà
de l'atmosphère de guerre ou du
terrorisme un peu partout maintenant
comme si c'était une chose normale
ce que vous dites c'est vrai si on va
aux halles maintenant on voit des soldes
hors norme comme choque toujours ces
jeunes gens tués par des militaires car
il ya des enfants qui refusent sans
connaissance non oui comme quand vous
dites ça j'ai pas compris ce que vous
disent exactement sur les états unis par
bourse
j'ai l'impression que c'était un moyen
en fait de permettre entre guillemets
aux états unis de pouvoir intervenir sur
ces zones là mais cette fois avec
l'accord des personnes qui ont été
témoins grâce aux économies en est un
moyen on a l'impression que c'est un
complot et la chose qu'ils atteindraient
voilà s'arrêter là maintenant ça pouvait
être le point de départ est cette fois
justifié parce qu'on avait vu ce que
c'était vraiment horrible et si les
images restent quand même très très
marquante et son c'est terrifiant ce
qu'on a vu alors a beau parler d'un
escape pour tout à l'heure il a il a
signé avec d'autres intellectuels
demande
cameron d'accueillir ddd des immigrants
en tout cas des réfugiés sur le
territoire anglais puisque le logo était
refusé pendant un petit moment puis
marseille et maintenant ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient en accueillant 20 milles
sur cinq ans dans ma boule énorme on va
on va donc parler de ce sujet d'aidés
des réfugiés et je vous à bord de deux
voies rapetisse usées et évidemment
comme comme dans toutes les régions de
france
daisy désigneront des migrants des
réfugiés arrivent en dans les yvelines
la loi fatigués par leur long voyage
mais le sourire aux lèvres ces réfugiés
expriment leur joie
chacun à sa façon
soixante dix huit réfugiés sont arrivés
à bonnel cet après-midi en bus depuis
munich 47 syrien 30 irakien et un
palestinien
leur arrivée au monastère dorante marque
la fin d'un très long périple pour
certains nous avons usé de tous les
moyens de transport voiture bateau de
sauvetage
après ce long voyage et après tous ces
kilomètres et ces pays
est ce que le monde a vu à budapest
c'est le début d'une victoire pour nous
d'être ici en sécurité en partenariat
avec la préfecture c'est l'association
habitat et humanisme qui a préparé leur
arrivée dans ce monastère une opération
s'organise depuis deux mois
deux familles étaient du voyage avec
trois enfants qui vont enfin pouvoir
apprécier le confort d'un crédit sans
échanges qui sont petites sans doute
trois petites mais entre ce que ces
personnes inconnues et puis si tu
n'aurais pas posée aujourd'hui en fait
il y avait renoncé comme le temps c'est
marie une lumière en faites pas pour
celle pour ces personnes c'est un lieu
de prendre soin quand un lieu de prendre
soin il faut que les gens qui ont
souffert ces dix mais finalement
l'accueil qu'on reçoit
c'est encore un accueil qui marque un
autre gars en fait du respect après un
court discours de bienvenue les réfugiés
ont rejoint le réfectoire pour prendre
leur premier repas chaud dans les jours
qui viennent ils seront soutenus dans
leur demande d'asile en préfecture
cet après midi priorité l'accueil humain
si vous permettait ce terme
ces deux
de savoir quels sont leurs besoins vous
avez vu il ya deux familles
mais quel besoin ils ont particuliers
qui prennent possession des lieux de
leurs chambres des lieux communs qui
mange un peu là déjà
et dès demain matin évidemment et de
manière accélérée renforcer tout ce qui
est accueil administratif demandeurs
d'asile demande d'asile et ça tue le
réfugié dans le laps de temps le plus
court possible
soixante places pourrait s'ajouter aux
80 déjà disponibles les réfugiés devrait
rester ici pendant un mois en attendant
de trouver une solution plus durable
mais pour eux c'est déjà un énorme
soulagement voilà alors cette question
des réfugiés c'est une question qui
perturbe un peu les opinions les
dirigeants politiques on voit bien que
personne ne sait exactement quelle
réponse il faut y apporter il ya même
des gens qui changent d'avis en deux
jours d'abord une question sur le terme
est ce qu'il faut faire la différence
entre réfugiés immigrés migrants ou est
ce que tout ça oui moi ce que je trouve
que c'est c'est à peu près la même chose
et sont ni santé de fête immigrés leur
migrants ch parce que ça veut dire on ne
peut presque parce que c'est des oiseaux
migrateurs enfin je sais pas ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens alors que ce sont
effectivement des immigrés ou des
réfugiés des réfugiés de guerre c'est
vrai que c'est une distinction qui est
importante on fait économiquement ou
statutairement statutairement fait
vraiment réfugiés après ce que c'est un
peu choquant dans tout ça c'est au-delà
du terme c'est que c'est une question où
on a l'impression qu'on peut sur
laquelle on peut plus poser aucune autre
question en terre canal discours ambiant
et 2 par exemple
je vais sûrement vous faire bondir mais
moi je peux je peux tout à fait
comprendre qu'il ya des gens qui se
disent il est curieux et qui est 140000
sdf en france qui n'est pas de logement
qu'on ne puisse pas nourrir qu'on ne
puisse pas réchauffer et puis là on va
tous temps là tout d'un coup trouver
dans toutes les villes des structures et
le préfet le disait là pour accueillir
l'occasion personnels numériques n'est
pas tout à fait tort c'est vrai qu'on a
entendues par exemple et des organismes
qui disent ah ben non on a des
possibilités de d'accueillir les
réfugiés sans arrêt des maires des
directeurs locaux les contours du
logement entend y a pas de problème mais
bien honda solis et qu'on allait démolir
paul démoli en valais loger là on à tel
endroit
je comprends je peux comprendre que des
gens qu'il est un peu mauvaise mais ça
n'enlève rien au fait que bien
évidemment une fois cueillies cesser ces
gens là et que c'est la vocation de deux
démocraties d'accueillir les gens qui
sont malheureux que ça en état de guerre
ça c'est une certitude mais si on fait
des efforts pour ces 24 mille je pense
qu'on pourrait mettre tout le monde dans
le même lot et faire des efforts pour
les cent quarante mille sdf français
voilà fédérer s'était je pensais
exactement la même chose que tu arrives
à fait réagir les gens aussi dans ce
sens là j'ai moi même des amis qui
attendent des logements depuis un bon
bout de temps qu'on fait des demandes à
la mairie et ça les a fait réagir d'une
façon assez négative tu vois on sent
bien dans l'opinion même si des sandales
sont un peu en train d'évoluer
il ya quand même une forte réticence et
sa grotte d'autant plus que ça ça amène
un sentiment de culpabilité on a peur de
le dire à haute voix mois et de peur de
passer pour le sauveur pour l'accueil
des réfugiés qui pensent le contraire
mais ce sens comptable est là c'est
encore je trouve encore plus dangereux
sont en connaît les conséquences
politiques que ça peut avoir par la
suite les gens qu'ils ne disent pas tout
ce qu'ils en pensent
bon bah non oui alors si c'est
effectivement ça a grondé on voit dans
les sondages vont avec une inversion
comme amoureuse moyenne pour 100 pages
une petite inversion qui fait un peu
chaud au coeur mais quand ça gronde je
ne suis pas sûr que si on vient dire aux
jambes a finalement les 140 milles on va
leur trouver des logements si ça va pas
continué à gronder aussi quand même
donc est-ce que le grondement de fonds
d un peu aussi contre tous ceux qui soi
disant viennent prendre les allocations
qu'on peut trouver en france ce prix
pour en tout cas pour les réfugiés dont
on parle aujourd'hui n'est absolument
pas c'est pas le problème et c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut poser la
question
alors ce qui est intéressant en termes
de vocabulaire c'est que pendant même
nom ah bah bien sûr que ça va coûter un
peu d'argent mais enfin quelqu'un qui
est en train de se noyer on lui tend la
main pas dire c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est l'évolution du
vocabulaire puisqu'on a parlé beaucoup
de migrants en tout cas sur vocabulaire
en france et à partir du moment où
l'allemagne a commencé à bouger à faire
des choses il y est allé d'un coup
maintenant on parle de réfugiés on parle
plus de migrants donc ce qui est aussi
se donner une espèce de bonne conscience
il doit de faire passer les choses ce
qui va pas la même résonance comme la
même résonance je rends plus réfute oui
c'est du marketing
mais le mot de réfugiés a une
connotation un peu juridique donc sk le
statut d'ailleurs sur les mots sont
importants et s'est pas installé mon
rapport on est enfin utilise un
vocabulaire conformes à la réalité
pour le coup je ris dit même si j'ai du
mal à concevoir cette notion la réalité
joly hm migrance un terme générique
quelqu'un qui change de qui changent de
place et qui migrent il été migré depuis
son pays il est immigré dans son pays
d'arrivée mais il s'agit alors s'ils
tentaient qu'on l'offre prat
reconnaissent la situation individuelle
de chacun mais a priori s'agit bien de
réfugiés au sens où l'entend la
convention de genève de 1951
c'est à dire que dans ce cadre là la
france est signataire de cette
convention internationale les états
signataires sont juridiquement obligés
d'accueillir des migrants auquel il
reconnaisse le statut de réfugié c'est
une obligation
et donc il n'y a pas à l'égard des
réfugiés alors réfugié de guerre etc
oui la convention de genève prend en
considération cette cette hypothèse là
tels que les gens
la subissent en syrie mais les états
n'ont pas du tout le même degré de deux
décisions ou de liberté à l'égard de ces
migrants là par rapport aux migrants
économiques ou etc ou les états
disposent là là on est dans une
obligation juridique parce que la france
a signé cette convention de genève
bon alors ceci étant dit et c'est vrai
pour a largement il ya un débat il ya un
débat alors c'est vrai que j'entendais
ce que jean-charles disait notamment
c'est vrai en attendant il ya cinq ans
cent quarante mille personnes qui sont
dehors à l'année mais j'entends aussi ce
que dit florence et je suis d'accord
avec elle
regardez la réaction des habitants d'un
quartier lorsque le maire leur dis ben
voilà il faut que l'on atteigne les
quotas de logements sociaux dans notre
commune 30% donc à côté de chez vous on
va construire de logements mixtes ont
construit jamais maintenant presque
jamais de logements sociaux uniquement
sociaux les logements sociaux
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps ils ne se
voient plus ils sont disséminés dans un
habitat assez homogène et regarder
généralement les réactions que suscite
cette annonce alors on voit ça beaucoup
au moment des élections municipales
donc est-ce que ce qui ronchonnent
aujourd'hui sont ceux aussi qui sont
prêts à accueillir à côté de chez eux
dans leur quartier les 140 milles le sdf
ça je n'en suis pas certain alors est ce
que dans la réaction politique
l'impression que c'est des réactions
plutôt à court terme qui ce qui se joue
c'est combien il faudrait dire combien
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire une fois que
qu'on les a accueillis est ce qu'il faut
faire des comptes réfugiés comme le
suggère nicolas sarkozy et puis les
renvoyer ensuite chez eux
mais est ce que c'est une bonne analyse
du problème est ce que au fond ce qu'on
voit arriver aujourd'hui avec la syrie
c'est pas quelque chose qui va les unes
pas une valve qui va monter de plus en
plus c'est pas quelque chose qui va à un
problème qui va rester et qui va se
poser pendant des années et des années
il a un truc un petit peu un petit peu
terrible c'est que beaucoup de
dejean fin tout cas les spécialistes ou
supposés tels nous annonce que pour
l'instant on aurait la crème de des
réfugiés qu'en fait les réfugiés qui
s'en vont pour l'instant sont des
docteurs son bac c'est plutôt les
horizons des avocats des lisiers dock hd
donc l'idée c'est que je sais c'est il
ya un côté extrêmement provocateur et
cynique qui dira mais prenons les tout
parce que cela ils s'alarment lecteurs
belges savent pas s'en servir c'est
vachement bien
donc ça c'est quand même un peu curieux
parce que quand on part comme de cette
image du petit gamin dans le salé puis
on en arrive à des considérations
économiques 1 en battant on manque de
toubib on a tous libres syriens qui
arrive allez hop on va les prendre
on va se les choisir et ça va être
merveilleux c'est un peu ce que ce que
ce cas de faire l'allemagne bon mais et
et mais au-delà de ça mais je voudrais
aussi rendre grâce à raffarin qui est
quand même il ya deux mois qui était le
premier à la dia installons des ces
réfugiés de la santé doit dans des
villages la vidéo sur johnny hallyday a
choisi d'y aller parce que ça vous
refait la même pour me disais tout le
monde sait le chante du rap s'est foutu
de raffarin il ya trois mois ses vues à
gauche comme à droite c'était c'est
ridicule ça inclut maintenant tous et ça
devient une bonne idée quoi ce type
aient eu raison de trois mois trop tôt
avec une idée était assez logique et
presque oui je sais pas si vous trouvez
est ce que c'est ça faire faire revivre
des villages c'est ce que parce qu'il y
avait aussi la volonté aussi des
réfugiés souvent talent et leur écran
dit pas non plus je dire parce que après
il faut pas tout mélanger et je la
crainte des réfugiés s'ils craignent
pour leur vie et ils ont bien raison et
j'aurais sûrement fait la même chose
donc après le réfugié de houmous
coiffeur à l'éviter à nantes que que
dans le poitou je viens c'est un peu un
problème de riche on verra plus tard si
pour l'instant on l'accueille en
accueille dans le poil tout il y en a
une maison d'enfants où est scolarisé et
comme n'y aura pas en tout cas dans
l'idée c'était s'était pas d'installer
deux cents 200 réfugiés dans un village
de 50 habitants mais mais mais de
respecter une sorte de proportions
agréable et évitable c'est sympa c'est
une bonne idée après qui préfère aller
en ville bombe après ils peuvent aller
violent mais
peut pas tout faire non plus c'est une
bonne idée a fallu six des leurs peuples
est vrai qu'il ya des endroits
désertifier enfance
c'est une idée que je trouve très
poétique il ya quelque chose de très
beau là dedans maintenant est ce que là
encore je pense que tu dis est ce que
des hôtels ça peut raconter à certaines
personnes et ce qu'ils avaient pas le
rêve justement de du grand paris est
juste valeur sont des gens qui ont aussi
une autre vision de la france et de
l'europe
est-ce que c'était celle de se retrouver
dans un village c'est pas forcément
évident mais sinon l'idée de base là je
la trouve belle
je pense que leur première motivation
c'était avant de dire oui et on va les
revoir
je suis enfin je suis pas certaine que
cette question se poserait également
déjà les choix quand même même dans
l'eure dans leur exode
parce que pour moi c'est blanche l'exode
ils ont fait quand même des choix de
pays qui accorde les mêmes produits mais
voilà ça y est c'est vraiment le choix
de la voilà donc à la loupe des le
village je pense que ça arrive encore
plus loin quoi c'est juste ça je
comprends que ce soit une mesure de
survie elle est naturelle mais une fois
qu'ils sont ici il voit les choses
différemment aussi d'autant plus si ce
sont des cadres ou des gens qui ont un
certain statut s'apprendre 9 ko sur dix
ont vite quitté paris alors je vais
quand même bizarre mais dans les
villages sur le fond du problème parce
qu'au fond il ya deux thèses
c'est simple il ya ceux qui disent il
faut fermer les frontières et puis être
ceux qui disent pour les ouvrir qui est
qu'elle est là quelle est la bonne
solution a été une bonne solution
d'abord et qu'elle est quelle est la
solution que vous préconisez vous la
solution c'est une question de
proportions c'est une question de
chiffres faire que là je pense que le
gouvernement est assez habile pour
encore une fois diviser les français sur
ce sujet il n'y a même pas de division a
souhaité c'est à dire que on parle de
24000 le gouvernement qui dit
la façon dont s'est amené c'est fait
pour diviser les français parce que
vingt-quatre mille personnes s'est rendu
c'est ridicule mais c'est vraiment
grotesque
donc normalement ça devrait en parler
deux minutes dans un journal télévisé et
puis c'est tout dire aucun accueilli 24
sur 74 64 inhabitants mais c'est
ridicule
il ya même pas de souci et là on en fait
une grande cause nationale
que faire de ces 24 mille qu'elles
soient en fait on monte et les gens sont
terrorisés parce que il s'imagine en
fait que c'est pas 24000 mais que ces 24
ses 240 milles ou 2 millions 400 me les
gens sont terrorisés par ainsi freddy
que parce qu'on leur présente ce chiffre
grotesque enfin l'hôtesse recensent le
plus sympa du terme et on leur présente
ça et ils sont terrorisés l'addition ce
soit le gouvernement qu'il fasse une
présentation de 24000 pour dire que
c'est la fin du monde je pense que c'est
plutôt les personnes de l'autre côté qui
ont une politique beaucoup plus radical
que ce soit nicolas sarkozy ou marine le
pen qui en montant en épingle pour dire
que c'est quand même beaucoup et qu'il
faudrait fermer qu'il faut revoir la
photographie
du magazine municipal de béziers oui il
arrive la direction béziers vraie
intrigue
oui il ya des gens qui joue avec les
peurs oui absolument
il arrive c'est la pêche du grand
remplacement de camus d'extraire alors
24000 c'est vrai que notre civilisation
va être bouleversée etc vous avez en
france aujourd'hui deux sens entre 200
et 250 mille personnes qui sont
justement sous le statut de réfugié est
ce que ça vous gêne à priori enfin voilà
donc 24 milles de plus et c'est vrai
qu'on regarde au regard de ce que font
les autres
enfin il faut aussi qu'on puisse se
regarder dans une glace un moment donné
regardez le renversement de situation
par rapport à l'allemagne par rapport à
des droits de l'homme est alors à 7 à la
chancelière qu'on présentait il ya six
mois comme étant une espèce de diable
européen avec la grèce et qu'on présente
aujourd'hui en madone à ceci près qu'en
france on le proposera en tout cas en ce
moment on ne propose pas des emplois à
payer un euro de l'heure alors qu'en
allemagne c'est quand même c'est ce que
je suis à quoi cesser ces gens vont être
confrontés donc mais est ce que ça vient
pas du fait alors la question qu'on pose
comme ça et le magazine de plaisir
notamment du fait qu'on a quand même
traiter la question de l'immigration
d'une façon générale depuis des années
au lieu de le traiter de façon
économique ou de façon décontractée si
je veux dire on en a fait un enjeu de
civilisation dans ce est-ce que c'est
pas ça qu'on paye un peu aujourd'hui
avec 24 mille réfugiés est en effet très
peu mais parce que c'est un enjeu de
civilisation parce que mais oui c'est
quand même de deux civilisations qui
sont pas forcément les mêmes et il ya
vraiment et encore une fois on peut dire
les choses sans être traître était deux
je ne sais quoi je veux dire c'est ce
sont des gens majoritairement musulman
du carré dans des pays majoritairement
dans le chrétien je viens de dire qu'il
ya pas deux
de deux confrontations entre deux
civilisations c'est nier l'évidence se
dit pas que c'est difficile
est ce que c'est le seul point fort de
l'immigration pointe pour les traiter
dans le dock point de vue économique il
semblerait que ça rapporte plutôt que ça
apporte de la croissance que 100000 et
100 mille immigrés ça fait un an
dépassant ses apports de richesse
on est tous d'accord avec ça que ça
apporte de la richesse et c'est un bien
évident il ya qu à regarder
bon ça se passe aux etats unis je crois
que c'est ces deux points de pipe par
parent l'immigration mais il n'y a pas
ce problème
ils font peut pas exclure le problème
religieux de soi qu'on redonne un peu
lié constituent les choses dans le
contexte avec des chiffres je suis allé
chercher des chips sur l'insee sur le
pourcentage de la population étrangère
en france et dans d'autres pays
européens
alors lindsay une vision assez
restrictive de ce que c'est que
l'étranger puisque c'est une personne
étrangère nés à l'étranger et qui vient
en france donc c'est vraiment sur une
haie en france sont à 6 2% de la
population qui est étrangère alors que
vous avez en allemagne à 9,4 pour cent
en autriche 11,8 en belgique 11,2 à
c'est pas énorme en irlande 11,8 en
espagne 10,9 royaume uni 7,7 alors juste
un peu juste pour rire parce que je suis
là il m'a fait un peu rire c'est la
pourcentage d'étrangers au luxembourg
est ce que vous avez une idée du
pourcentage d'étrangers au luxembourg 12
car 44,5 pour le commander mais voilà
donc vous voyez de plus en plus de
l'hexagone il ya trente ans on avait
quatre millions d'étrangers en france on
en a de 5.5 n'y a pas d'explosion il n'y
a pas de confrontation fin des chiffres
sont quand même faut les remettre aussi
mais on en fait un problème on en fait
un problème et le le port sont plus de
la moitié sont des gens qui sont
européens
donc c'est ça qui est important il 63 %
des immigrés ils ont un équivalent du
bac femmes ont donc faut quand même un
peu resituer ça et on a deux fois moins
de demandeurs d'asile en france
qu'ailleurs il faudrait peut-être se
poser les bonnes questions aussi sûr que
j'ai fait
je doute pas de la véracité de thé shins
et 2013 l'exactitude de toutes ces
données
c'est aussi avec aussi peu de gens
comment se fait-il qu'il y ait autant de
problèmes et que on en parle sans arrêt
pourquoi est ce que dans toutes les
chorales et dynamique
pourquoi c'est dans toutes les cantines
et un débat pour savoir ce qu'on va
donner à manger le vendredi ou le
mercredi
machin est ce qu'il faut des moyens pas
dans tout ce qui revient dans deux ans
c'est un problème électoraliste et
j'espère qu'ils courent après le front
national
abbas et pointant gala merkel est prête
à poser la toiture avec la droite quand
les maires de gauche sont des repas de
substitution c'est quand même pas de la
faute de la droite et dont tout le monde
va faire des repas type pour les
végétariens d'accord pas pourquoi
et est ce que est ce que l'un est ce que
la religion doit entrer dans le est-ce
qu est ce qu ont ils une seule école en
france on oblige les français enfin les
élèves à manger du poisson de vendredi
jamais c'est fini c'est terminé on n'en
parle même plus on mange si on est
chrétien catholique pratiquant on mange
du poisson chez soi le soir et personne
ne lira jamais dans une école communale
jamais vu un parent d'origine catholique
dira au maire à cet instinct scandale il
nous faut du poisson à médine ont alors
pourquoi est-ce que non non ça n'existe
pas de trouver moi des gens c'est ça
n'existe pas alors c'est parce qu'il y
avait de moins en moins de pratique
qu'elle envoie lycos y avait même des
bâtons c'est aussi ça le problème
d'où la main pour secte de pratiques
s'arrête à la porte de l'école et des
cantines pas de problème ne sait si on
ne met pas le doigt sur les problèmes si
on ne les crée pas il n'aura peut-être
pas effectivement mais d'accepter comme
ça à chaque fois de lâcher du lest
l'étudiant a oui effectivement un souci
mais une pratique qui était courante
pourquoi ce que maintenant on dit on va
plus la faire cette pratique là c'est le
choc n'était pas courant du tout le
temps je me souviens il ya 15 ans quand
on prenait l'avion sur air france vient
vers tim aucun souci maintenant on prend
l'avion sur la france examine maintenant
radio avec rassurez-vous ce repas ne
tienne ne contient pas de porc mais vous
et toi mais non mais
non désolé c'est ce qu'on dit est ce que
ça vient faire patrice morisod jeu
il ya une tension sur cette question au
migratoires en france qu'on ne retrouve
pas dans les pays clés on parlait alors
c'est vrai qu'ils sont on dit ce sont
des pays d'immigration ils n'ont pas la
même histoire voilà l'histoire etc
moi je pensais aussi au canada qui est
un par excellence un pays d'immigration
ou en effet n'y a pas ce genre de
tensions mais il ya aussi une une
instrumentalisation politique évidente
on sait que à partir du moment où la
france a franchi le cap du million de
chômeurs c'était il ya longtemps
souvenez vous de ce que le jean pierre
stirbois parce que c'est apparemment ce
serait lui plus ou moins l'inventeur de
cette formule 1 million de chômeurs égal
1 millions d'immigrés ou un million
d'immigrés lorsque le front national à
paris en 1904 à partir de 1984 a
commencé à apparaître sur le pad re
malheureuse sur le plan électoral et on
n'en sort pas de cette équation
comme c'est assez on ne parviendra est
ressorti personnes essayent de traiter
ce problème d'une autre façon que ce
soit avec l'ipod et en disant mais la
stabilisation de mai si certains jeux je
me souviens des ouvrages l'immigration
est une chance pour la france est de
stasi par exemple vers la stasi a essayé
il a toujours été battu mais alors que
n'avait-il pas écrit et dit avec ce qu
il est et il était plutôt certains
centristes
justement parlons peut-être de 2,2
politique puisque il vu la conférence de
presse de françois hollande ce que vous
disiez est ce que si on veut régler le
problème du chômage est ce que ça ne
réglerait pas en partie tous les autres
problèmes derrière dont celui de
l'immigration
c'est possible si on voit qu en tout cas
on pourrait peut-être les traités de
façon un peu différente
alors
y'a rien de plusieurs plusieurs choses
avant de parler peut-être de la
conférence de presse de hollande il ya
quand même les sondages qui se
multiplient qui montre qu'il serait
absent du deuxième tour si les élections
présidentielles avait dû aujourd'hui
pour regarder sondages comme ça ça vous
intéresse non mais mais il arrive qu'on
en discute entre amis etc
donc c'est comme ça que je peux que je
suis quand même contrainte d'en parler
mais en général je devrais je regarde
très près ça vous intéresse peu les
hommages qui lui ont fait aujourd'hui
sur ce qu'il se passera dans deux ans à
peu près je trouve que c'est pour moi
s'ils ont plutôt une portée anxiogène et
peut-être que je me trompe possible j'ai
trouv sont réorientés c'est pour ça que
j'évite de mai quand même là il ya
plusieurs sondages récurrents qui montre
que voilà le le si c'est hollande qui
est candidat pour la gauche qui ne
serait pas au deuxième tour pour c'est
que ça pose quand même un problème non
ça vous pose un problème à lui est bien
qu'il s'en défende mes visiteurs à la
materia bas etc
il y aura pas de primaires il y aura pas
tout est fait aux pratiques pour que ce
soit lui le candidat à sa propre
succession mais un moment peut-être que
le problème se pose est de savoir si il
ya une partie saucisses ne ferait pas
mieux de te présenter quelqu'un d'autre
vous savez c'est enfin il faut ici si
nicolas sarkozy parvient à gagner les
siennes de prix
je pense que sarkozy est le meilleur
rassembleur de la gauche en france alors
don de leurs rêves de bah oui mais je
pense que sarkozy est un rassembleur de
la gauche plus efficace et plus que la
droite
donc voilà peut-être que ma femme en
deux volets dire que les choses peuvent
évoluer mais ça je suis d'accord avec
monsieur voilà c'est plutôt mal parti
pour lui est-ce que ça pose un pôle de
gouvernance d'ailleurs les sauveurs
comme ça de digitimes fond
les bons les politistes savent très bien
expliquer tout cela c'est à dire que
c'est un gouvernement non plus par le
peuple mais c'est un gouvernement on
appelle ça un agrément d'opinion alors
qui est l'opinion qu'est ce que c'est
mais le pignon c'est insaisissable c'est
pas l'opinion qu'ils votent ce n'est pas
l'opinion qui gouvernent mais c'est
l'opinion qui dicte un peu son sa
sonorité avec ce diapason qu'on entend
régulièrement vous avez vu le csa
monsieur schrameck est favorable à ce
qu'on publie les sondages jusqu'à la
veille de l'élection
en effet c'est une belle de soi disant
ce que toute façon le vent les a regardé
autour parce qu'on les avait mais alors
c'était une industrie les sondages et
puis c'est vrai que ça alors ça ça
alimente ça alimente la vie politique
qui se cale un peu enfin les élus sont
responsables de tout cela une fois de
plus les gens aussi selon les questions
qui leur sont posées répondu des choses
qui leur paraissent politiquement
correct et qui brave staff là là là où
parler ce sondage d'opinion sur des
élections c'est lula il ya moi de vous
avez raison sur certains droits il a
surclassé sa mécanique médias - allier
mois de choix de réponse vous avez
apporté le alors c'est la grande réforme
à laquelle on s'attend maintenant après
le pacte de stabilité
après un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont quand même été très favorable aux
entreprises et aux entrepreneurs et aux
chefs d'entreprise on arrive à ce code
du travail ça a été ça était d'ailleurs
assez bien amené et d'abord le livre de
bananes un duo camp qui détient il
faudrait réduire le le le code du
travail leur dit vous êtes en service
commandé pas du tout qu'il disait vrai
après une macro devant l'université du
medef et aujourd'hui voilà ce rapport
qui est plutôt modéré presque par
rapport à ce qu'on a dit avant et qui
arrivent comme comme la solution
peut-être c'est vrai qu'il est bon oui
j'ai apporté le rouge sont mal bleu
aussi quelqu'un il est rouge c'est
anxiogène enfin mais tous les côtés
les 400 vous avez les côte bleue
lexisnexis fait plaisir un jour chat
alors alors alors celui ci je sais pas
si inquiet mais voilà celui ci je me
tourne la tranche à côté de celui ci
alors celui sont le bleu a vu les bottes
dans le kg 200 g
voilà est alors celui ci c'est le code
qui regroupe c'est le droit européen du
travail d'accord qui fait 280 pages
contre notre code du travail
alors pour revenir à cette complexité du
code du travail c'est vraiment le jeu
flemme le problème
absent des temps modernes c'est un vrai
problème
simplement quand on regarde le rapport
qui a été remis par jean denis
combrexelle
il ne parle pas de réécrire le code ou
de supprimer
il a contourné non il parle pas de
contourner il parle de réorganiser le
code du travail en deux parties avec une
première partie qui va être l'ordre
social public sur lequel personne ne
pourra faire quoi que ce soit des rejets
qui sera sur l'emploi sur le salaire sur
les conditions de travail et sur le
temps de travail
donc ça en fait on va réorganiser tout
ce à quoi donc
dans une première partie sur ce point là
il y en aura une deuxième partie qui va
encadrer les modalités de négociations
entre les partenaires sociaux donc il y
aura la négociation mais l'égalisation
va se faire sur deux aspects en dessous
donc on va voir le code et ensuite on va
avoir les négociations de branche
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on à 700 branches ce qui
est quand même absolument hallucinant et
on ne peut pas faire grand chose avec
700 mange donc la boucle intro donc
qu'il va imposer aux branches qui
représente moins de 5000 salariés de
fusionner donc on devrait arriver d'ici
2020 à passer de 700 branche à 100
branche
ce qui va aussi donner un peu plus de
lisibilité et en matière de négociations
aussi ça va être quand même un peu plus
simple et un peu plus fluide et au
niveau des branches
on va avoir ce qu'on appelle l'ordre
public conventionnelle donc à l'ordre
public social incontournable du code
ensuite leur public conventionnel qui va
organiser sept ans public social au
niveau des branches et en fonction des
activités
et comme quand la risée c'est un peu un
contournement c'est à dire que l'idée
générale c'est de passer de la loi à la
négociation
on va essayer de repousser on va
repousser un certain nombre de sujets
puisque sur la pénibilité sur l'avenir
en relation sur la durée du temps de
travail par exemple alors sur la durée
glossy à bhl sur la durée du temps de
travail ce qui est de jean denis
combrexelle a écrit en tout cas il a dit
on va pouvoir faire bouger le seuil de
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
qui aujourd'hui est au delà de 35 heures
jusqu'à 35 heures n'est pays normal et
au delà de 35 heures heures effectuées
sont payés majoré et il a proposé mais
que ce soit fait dans un cadre défini
par la loi donc ce cette façon de
repousser le seuil ne pourrait être fait
qu'une fois qu'on aura pris loi qui doit
être prise d'ici la fin de l'année 2016
donc on sait pas encore si on va pouvoir
négocier en disant voilà la durée légale
va rester à 35 heures puisque ça ils
vont pas y toucher mais est-ce que par
accord de branche ou accords
d'entreprise va pouvoir dire ben nous on
déclenche les heures sup à partir de 39
heures par exemple et entre 36 et 39 ans
et payer le loyer sans majoration de
l'amap façon donc ça lui il a pris une
précaution de dire parce qu'au départ
sont deux rapports ne disait pas que
c'était dans un cadre défini par la loi
l'amarrage la loi c'est dans un cadre
défini par la loi donc c'est pas aussi
explosif que que ce qu'on veut bien dire
qu'on pouvait le craindre ou vrai parce
que j'espère est selon de la sas que
s'il ya un vrai problème enfin sur le la
négociation que les négociations soient
mieux que la loi c'est c'est tout c'est
une possibilité enfin beaucoup de gens
le disent depuis longtemps mais on a
quand même une faiblesse endémique des
syndicats en france qui fait que peu de
monde qui négocient quoi et dans ce cas
là qui va être là ils le savent
sinon le salarié voilà il impose ce qui
peut être protecteur des salariés c'est
que les accords soient signés par des
syndics un ou plusieurs syndicats qui
représentent 50% des voix aux dernières
élections professionnelles aujourd'hui
ses 30
donc il a repoussé le curseur à 5 ans
donc c'est quand même plus protecteurs
l'essai
et si on n'a pas les cervicales ok alors
si on n'a pas un syndicat
il ya la possibilité de faire des
négociations dans les entreprises donc
ça c'est pour les petites entreprises
tpe pme qui n'ont pas de syndicats et
qui vont pouvoir négocier avec les
représentants du personnel 6 ans non ou
directement avec les salariés s'ils
n'ont pas de représentants du personnel
donc ça ça ouvre quand même beaucoup de
champ pour les petites entreprises qui
n'avaient pas des possibilités de faire
des négociations quand on n'avait pas de
délégués du personnel directement par
voie de vote puisque les salariés votent
et font un référendum ce qui se passe
chez smart mais j'y vois là parce que
chez smart l'accorte l'a proposé de
consulter les salariés de faire un
référendum ce document ça c'est prévu
par le code du travail aujourd'hui on
peut le faire avant de mettre en place
des accords des accords d'intéressement
très grand tournoi de sa vie car ça
tourne ça qu'on tombe pas comme ça pas
de syndicat dans l'entreprise ont fait
sens donc mais ça c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui avait fait sauter justement le
monopole des syndicats dans la
négociation des accords donc ça ça
remonte déjà à 2008 a dit ton personnel
comme ça alors juste si je peux tenir
juste sur un petit point c'est que les
branches vont pouvoir mettre en ligne
des modèles d'accord pour aider les tpe
pme a signé les accords parce que c'est
vrai que les grandes entreprises elles
sont elles sont tout ce qu'il faut ils
sont armés pour rédiger faire des
voyages est d'accord
vous serez sur la rédaction là le
branché c'est prévu dans le rapport
combrexelle les branches vont avoir des
modèles d'accord qui vont être mis en
ligne par les branches pour que les tpe
pme si elles veulent proposer des
accords après ils peuvent les modules et
les a et négociants diack et je pense
qu'un accord qui est négocié par des
tpe/pme directement avec les salariés
avec un référendum sera beaucoup plus
fort peut-être qu'un accord qui sera
signé par des syndicats sans forcément
que la base soit nécessairement
consultez donc surtout compte tenu du
problème de la faiblesse de nos
syndicats et c'est bien pour ça que les
syndicats sont contre le renvoi vers la
négociation parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
sont faibles et ça c'est un vrai
problème de fond félicité le soir je
vais travailler à pôle emploi
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les entreprises parfois été n'engagez
pas parce que c'est trop compliqué parce
qu'ils trouvent de réglementation parce
que ya ce problème là et je sais que
pôle emploi propose justement d
et des aides aux entreprises pour
proposer un employé des personnes à des
tarifs pour des salaires qui seront
comment m'exprimer voilà et qui évite
justement aux patrons aux employeurs
d'avoir une tonne de paperasse à remplir
l'argument pour leur donner un chapeau
503 on leur disait toujours nous nous
occupons de tout et ça c'était
l'argument qui qui déclenchait les
rendez vous toujours d'accord nous aider
l'emploi tout à fait vrai qu'il ya eu
mais manquent de démarches à chaque fois
quand on veut embaucher quelqu'un et
justement notamment pour les contrats de
travail
donc quand on leur dit on s'occupe de
tout ne vous inquiétez pas et en plus y
aura des subventions c'était bon coup
pour des rendez vous quoi alors c'est
vrai que on voit à quoi le le le la
démarche de tout ça c'est à dire que à
la fois on peut lutter contre le chômage
mais au prix d'une sorte de
précarisation quand même des situations
de salariés non c'est ça ou c'est pas ça
jamais ben je pense que le fond le fond
des choses et là et alors on tourne
autour du pot évidemment de manière plus
ou moins habile mais falla le fond de la
question est vraiment là parce que au
fond cette cette masse la cette
épaisseur de code du travail dit
beaucoup de ce que nous sommes nous de
soi gars est aussi gros et personne et
tout le monde c'est à dire que pour
pourquoi pourquoi est ce que c'est si
lourd alors si incompréhensible vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est peut-être
pas si grave qu'on ne comprennent rien
au code du travail
je crois que si quand même passé ne pas
que ne plus comprendre la loi ça ne
s'impose vraiment de très très grosses
difficultés jusqu'à alors je ne devrais
pas le dire mais il ya une semaine était
très forte à ses côtés jusque juste part
et pour adebayor pour l'exemple des
magistrats qui sont chargés de faire
appliquer la loi
ma qui m'ont dit tout et ça ce truc là
on prend paris est donc au-delà de la
simplification oui parce que derrière
tout cela il ya sept cette question là
qui se posent à simplifier ce sera déjà
très bien clarifié m alors bon courage
parce que dès que le législateur dit
nous allons simplifier
parfois c'est encore pire mais là sur le
fond des choses on avance à petits pas
la négociation c'est vrai on n'a pas de
culture de négociation on l'a très peu
souvenez vous alors de ne puis je sais
pas l'époque de la participation général
de gaulle au carré ça car j'ai souvent
essayé mais c'est vrai que tant qu'on
aura pas de syndicats forts
ça m'a alors dans les 44 propositions de
combrexelle il y en a plus de 20 sur la
formation des magistrats des élèves des
avocats de tous les intervenants à la
négociation et au dialogue social
il ya une vingtaine de propositions sur
très pédagogique là dessus il ne resta
pas deux minutes
sinon il ya la méthode du ministère de
la justice qui s'est complètement a
franchi pendant quarante 40 mille
personnes au sens code du travail soit
en contrat de travail à les faire bosser
au noir il ya plus de c'est la
profession ça qu'on fait c'est peut-être
château on avait toujours des mutations
sociales voilà on n'a pas le temps de
parler beaucoup de choses je relève qu
on abordera peut-être la prochaine fois
il ya un livre de daniel cohen qui est
un économiste qui explique qu'au fond on
est en train d'entrer dans une société
où la croissance ne mènera pas d'emplois
et donc par conséquent qu'il faut
peut-être reconsidérer notre façon et
d'abord de protéger les salariés et de
croire que la croissance va forcément
être la solution à tous nos maux
on ne m'aime pas le temps de parler de
la reine d'angleterre mais il y avait
quand même un sujet je voulais qu'on
traite avec vous cette femme je ne suis
pas monarchiste ni royaliste 1 la messe
qui veut lui l'amateur de chapeau
aideront sais pas si vous avez vu vous
avez la conférence de presse du
président de la république avait tout le
gouvernement est ce qu'il vaut mieux
quand même
et pas quand même une monarchie
démocratique küng république monarchique
j'ai combien de temps patrice possession
vous avez 2 à raconter comment il va se
mettre gamme usant c'est que la reine
d'angleterre coûte moins cher que le
président m'a république oui mais alors
c'est un peu mon coup mais elle a connu
elle a connu fin ça faisait pas beaucoup
plus est quand même non soixante trois
ans et sept points de rennes c'est comme
will après 1945 maintenant les
monarchies aujourd'hui leur importance
ou delà du décorum et de la tradition
c'est des prêts démocratie la grande le
royaume uni est l'inventeur du de la
démocratie parlementaire
quand même pas rien mais vous vous
regardez le rôle que jouent certains
certaines monarchies en europe je pense
à la monarchie belge par exemple dans un
pays totalement éclaté après plusieurs
nations la nation belge n'existe pas la
monarchie et ben ouais c est ce que de
ce que disent les séparatistes et 10 la
belgique maintenant ça se limite à un
roi et quelques bières et une équipe de
foot voilà et ben on va terminer des
diables rouges
on va terminer sur cette bonne parole
merci infiniment
stéphane minson merci florence père
cadets choqué merci félicité d' idole et
on verra mais bon ça va merci sortir la
jaunisse rappel voilà d'olivier morel au
dessus des horizons verticaux acheter le
progrès le lisez le
on voudrait pas m'adresserai vous
remercie mois là merci à tous